If we show emotion, we're called dramatic.
If we want to play against men, we're nuts.
And if we dream of equal opportunity, delusional.
When we stand for something, we're unhinged.
When we're too good there's something wrong with us.
And if we get angry...
...we're hysterical, irrational or just being crazy.
But, a woman running a marathon is crazy.
A woman boxing was crazy.
A woman dunking, crazy.
Coaching an NBA team, crazy.
A woman competing in a hijab.
Changing her sport.
Landing a double cork 1080.
Or winning 23 grand slams,...
...having a baby and then coming back for more.
Crazy, crazy, crazy, crazy and crazy.
So, if they want to call you crazy, fine.
Show them what crazy can do.